[Music]
they repeal meme review that's right
everybody YouTube's
most voted top show up thank you guys we
did it
I'm so proud Oh boom gah I hope to god
you will never hear those words Oh Bunga
he seized you when you are sleeping
opanka he knows if you're awake oh yeah
that's right everybody I'm talking about
Oh boom gah you guys didn't heard about
this you know about this Oh bunk
everybody you may think his name is
Obama holy heck that was super scary
perhaps so Bunga can be the next five
nights at freddy's oh my gosh guys dude
this is gonna get millions of hits on
youtube lit stop calling me o Bunga
Barack Obama excuse me
Barack Obama but I see through your
longer lives I just realized this joke
is slightly racist damn it which makes
it so much better that was a joke
everybody Bush the joke went right over
your head Oh Bunga of course doesn't
only have to be spooky and scary Obama
can be excuse me for having an opinion
full disclaimer don't dislike this video
for me giving this opinion but it will
get can be very cute that's like I said
it haters you know what Oh Bunga instead
sumimasen
marzia Shh go to the side o Bunga o
Bunga come here
[Music]
if you say open three times in the
mirror
you wouldn't even dare you wouldn't even
dare if you comment or bunga bunga bunga
three times and smash that like button
on a PT Pi video or Bunga is going to a
Bunga okay so don't do it whatever you
do do not subscribe and hit the Bell
button and type O Pogo booga-booga loli
didn't work now let's change the meme
guys cuz this is just too scary the new
Nintendo switch announcement came out
for the new character and it's finally
finally going to be damn you stop
summoning a boom guy guys please this is
not some sort of game alright
changing meme hey we're okay we have a
sexy girl alright yeah I like that I
like that now this this is epic okay
alright what did we get damage you could
kill me do you not care okay moving on
next me alright what's the real next
cares
umm smash alright oh my god it's well
Luigi finally thank you Thank You Wayne
[Music]
stop it stop with your bunga bunga meme
gets of course
Olga Bunga a boo-boo 5000 a room gets
nice right
how did all of you goodbye next mean
what happened to me from number 13 a
child the last place you would want to
lose your child is in a sewer drain oh I
wasn't so bad number 13 13 a child a
child number 30 a child their life say
you wanted her burger is a child who
gives me the creeps there's children
next mean Incredibles - have you heard
about this you know about this you heard
about this huh Incredibles 2 star
Elastigirl is heck whatever that means
why that's a good thing why people are
quick to point out my god what's the
lycée girl always that thick I mean I
get it rubber is extremely attractive
nothing that turns me on than a piece of
rubber ear ooh I like to froze it down
because then it's useless and that's how
I like my women
Chardin of controversy taught a drama
around lasted girl and Ice ago proved
superhero women can incoming both thick
and finally a progressive film finally
when is a Disney star going to prove
that it's okay to be thick and thin I've
asked this a million times
finally we have a superhero where every
man who's in true intellect can agree
that damn she is thick comments like
mrs. incredible has got some thick booty
mrs. incredible can get this D letter I
swear she does have a nice ass she thick
heart heart heart she is extra thick and
of course what's very incredible is that
ass The Incredibles more like the
indigestible I mean it looks like
there's
something wrong with her should we be
concerned finally Disney movie that
troubles in digestion a lot of people
seem to be surprised about this somehow
acting like Miss aunty from robot didn't
exist
hey permits of course is always gotta be
the contrarians hey perverts stop
staring at you like stickers but you
can't stop me oh yeah mainstream media I
don't think so
but the most shameless display of
appreciation for alas the girls but has
to be this article from The New Yorker
Incredibles 2 review by Anthony Lane and
can we get some classy music please
listen carefully and you may just hear a
shifty sound as of parents squirming
awkwardly beside their enraptured
offspring and why kids because mommy
just leaned over to Daddy and whispered
is it just me or does mrs. incredible
kind of look like Anastasia in Fifty
Shades of Grey you know the girl in the
red room with a whips on oh and daddy
just rested Jesus just rested his
cooling soda firmly on his lap and like
mr. incredible tried very hard to think
of algebra this is a review for a kids
movie as for how daddy will react later
on during the scene in which Helen in
the husky boys Evelyn's earned wind and
simply talk woman-to-woman I hate to
think but watch out for flying popcorn
from
[Music]
of course of course there's people
shaming The New Yorker holy crap what's
with the new New Yorker review of The
Incredibles gross
Amanda bong more like a main dat wall
you're wrong about I didn't mean for
that to come off crass races I just
realized it so I will retract the joke
everybody now which is gone let's forget
about that one Incredibles 2 reviewed a
sequel in the shadow of a masterwork
they might as well call this I want to F
the cartoon The Incredibles 2 review by
Anthony Lane is very good but what I
personally prefer is the minions to
review I want to F immediate fist bump
the screen right now if you want to as
well hell yeah
and all this controversy about butts
this and what's that what's really
really important here the real message
that we need to channel our anger
towards it's the fact that they nerfed
snakes ass
is that one talking about this there's
no one even gonna bring this up look how
thick that leftist and look how oh I
don't even want to look at snake's ass
anymore
before I could enjoy the snake games
this now I can't enjoy the snake games
and if we're gonna talk about thickness
I wanna end this on this note by melon
himself
damn damn boy I'm not gonna read this
mean because it's too important if I
watch out for flying popcorn it gets a
flying popcorn the next meme is a man
walking on the street wait a minute it's
just lost oh my gosh successful people
unsuccessful people people who thanked
the bus driver when they get up that's
right everybody are you part of the
secret elite the taught that 1% of the
1% that thanks the bus driver
when you get off cuz I do every time and
that's how I know my grave will have
plated gold in Egyptian style in my own
little dungeon anxiety but if you're not
good enough
depression everyone hates you bus driver
hey you forgot to thank me oh no no this
has not happen to me number one we text
all the time ok
and you saved us mr. bus driver xx love
you xx
number two I will never never forget to
pass and thank that bus driver never
cultural people have a nice day have a
nice weekend see ya thank all these
things must be said to the Blessed
driver otherwise don't even consider
yourself an intellectual ok this is what
you see mm-hmm a regular potato chip you
might say well this is what I see and
other fellow members that think the bus
driver okay it's an hyperbolic
paraboloid and everybody knows that and
you could know it too you just have to
thank the bus driver hey don't make me
pull a gun on you you will thank the bus
driver I'm doing this for you not for me
if you're a virgin
you might consider thanking the bus
driver because it gets women going oh la
la ooh la la
very nice so from zero from zero from
verging - ha ha very good sing thanks to
the bus driver giving bus driver some
shrimp that is also acceptable in some
cultures of course you got to make sure
that you study up on these things are
you writing this down are you even
paying attention LM out that kid doesn't
even thank the bus driver what's the
matter Ethan too much of a [ __ ] to to
venerate working class actions ah you're
not even been reading working class act
Ethan Ethan Ethan hate that knee never
liked that name saying thank you to the
bus driver yes of course yes of course
1% 1% but asking the bus driver how
their day was 1% 1% 1% of people but the
top of the top the CEO of the CEOs the
world presidents of the universe offered
the bus ride home thank you everybody
I hope this has been educational for you
as it has for me leave a like if you
enjoyed this video and make sure to rate
this meme and I thank you to the bus
driver everybody my name is felix kajal
burg and you've just been phill'd in i
see you tomorrow